members will discuss the e use response
to the corona virus pandemic with the
council and Commission Parliament will
examine the 500 billion euro rescue plan
for countries hit hard by the virus and
set out its view on the crisis exit
strategy Parliament will vote on the
release of three billion euros of
emergency support for the healthcare
sector under the e use emergency support
instruments and the civil protection
mechanism rescue you it would allow the
purchase distribution and transport of
medical supplies a sit cross-border
patient transport and help set up mobile
field hospitals the EU is committed to
supporting the poorest and most
vulnerable especially during the
pandemic Parliament will vote on changes
to the fund for European aid to the most
deprived so it can continue to provide
food aid and material support to those
most in need
MEP s will examine extra funding to
boost border patrols build new reception
centres in the Greek islands and improve
medical facilities in the camps
Parliament is expected to approve more
support for European fishermen fish
farmers and agri-food producers along
with additional measures to make
cohesion and rural development funds
more flexible